foreign
Ty
it's me Tyrus
not to be confused with the little guy
he's actually under the chair
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests her
favorite government program would be one
that eliminates government programs hope
many New Yorkers have remorse that they
backed the wrong horse former New York
Congressman Lee zeldin
she knows more jackasses than a donkey
co-host of the bottom line on Fox
Business the Degen McDowell
[Applause]
if the world was her oysters she'd
probably get food poisoning Fox News
contributor cat Tim
foreign
it's Friday so before we get into some
new stories it's time for this
Greg's leftovers hmm
I don't think anyone ever said um with
Greg leftovers
yeah it's leftovers why are we jokes we
didn't use this week and just like when
Greg does it except taller it's my first
time reading these here we go
The View finally lifted its studio
audience mask requirements although
doctors still recommended they wear
blindfolds and earplugs
oh boy we're getting into it aren't we
all right
it also begs the question when will the
host take off their masks
[Applause]
Halloween was five months ago
the vine Administration on what roll
back down what is
they always the admission oh they made
the word so big that administration's
two lines so I was like a minute
straight on no the Biden Administration
is suing to block JetBlue's 3.8 billion
dollar purchase of Spirit Airlines
officials claim the merger is all part
of a bigger plan to create the world's
largest flight
latest flight
[Laughter]
thank you
apparently I'm going blind as we speak
a biological male weightlifting in
Minnesota has won a court judgment to
compete in women's powerlifting events
to prove she's not a man she says if she
gets lost on the way to the contest
she'll definitely ask for directions
[Applause]
it is true
scientists in Switzerland say they've
developed a robotic robotic third arm
that can help people with daily chores
oh god
wow now I can really multitask during
work call said Jeffrey too good
[Applause]
thank you
kind of knew it was going there
the Kimmel will host the 95th annual
Academy Awards and to help boost
Radiance Kimmel has offered to slap
himself
[Applause]
is once again offering their Double Down
sandwich which replaces a traditional
bun with two pieces of fried chicken as
a result customers will have to replace
the traditional art with one from a
donor
in other words that's just fat tacular
a new report from the world obesity
Federation claims that more than half
the world's population will be
overweight by 2035.
hey the more the merrier said Michael
Moore's cream cheese Butler
[Laughter]
fat when you have a butler for specific
Foods
cottage cheese
Dagan has a whiskey Butler
foreign
[Applause]
your cheese is ready
[Laughter]
while discussing his plans for the 2024.
Donald Trump suggested that America
should develop a to develop flying cars
to which an angry Pete Buddha just
responded we already have that sir and
they're called trains
[Applause]
oh and finally this week's Sunny D juice
brand announced the launch of a new
Tangy orange vodka seltzer doctors say
it could help alcoholics by making vodka
taste like
and nice job writing staff nice job man
now some news because this is Fox News
after all
will voters support the presidential
push from a Florida Governor not named
Bush
I'm not rhyming but I had no choice I
couldn't think of another person coming
out of Florida anonymous
sourcing post that Ron DeSantis is
indicating privately he intends to run
for president in 2024.
and that Jesse Watters Harris falls out
when he pees
how would you know
do we hate Jesse that much all right
oh
a political committee reportedly
launched yesterday that will likely
raise money for his campaign what about
Jesse's hair all right
you'll need a lot of cash if he tends on
clearing the field like a farmer that
hires illegal immigrants
what you want to work for free
as much cash as it would take to hire a
Joy Reid to speak and clear the field
for him
uh let's put this into a video game
metaphor because I'm a sucker for a good
metaphor
first Ron will have to defeat boss
number one which is actually a couple
bosses the Nikki Haley's and the vivec
Rams way hopefully I didn't destroy that
then enter boss number two the biggest
baddest McDonald's loving boss of all
president Donald Trump
he's got fans and insults and it'll be
like going against Dice Clay in the 80s
apparently no one remembers Dice Clay in
the 80s
he did this thing with a cigarette you
put it like this and he said hey yo and
cussed a lot
yeah
I didn't know it would be tonight that I
knew it was over for dice
wow yeah Big Dice fans all right that
won't be an easy battle since and it
says a new poll suggests they're tied up
in Iowa like Greg on vacation
and finally the last boss old Joe
himself
although that'll be a cake
we don't do that here
and that'll be a cakewalk since he can't
even walk up the stairs
he's such a bad candidate even his brain
left
so much
I'd have to vote for them I wouldn't be
black
I've been auditioning for Latinos but
they haven't called me back yet so I'll
just have to wait
Joe raises his feet about as well as his
son raises illegitimate children
[Applause]
Joe
hey hey uh come on man I don't care
about this stuff I mean I'll run against
any of these guys orange man bad Florida
man bad it doesn't matter to me
yeah besides all I do is go in the
basement they do all the rest you know
racism white supremacy that whole deal
and so I feel pretty good I gotta tell
you something I know it's Friday
the month it is
cat are you surprised the rumors that
DeSantis is running no I think
everybody's kind of expecting him to run
um and I think that the way that he's
sort of handled Trump so far has been
super interesting because he just hasn't
like Trump will go after him and he just
doesn't address it which if you try to
get into like a verbal battle with Trump
you're probably gonna lose because he'll
get really mean and you know he's funny
like Trump is funny uh and Ron's just
like not doing it so I wonder what that
would look like if it was between Trump
and Ron and Ron kind of refused to let
it be that way
yeah I would it's good that's definitely
going to be interesting do you think
it's a problem I hear that a lot like
you have to is DeSantis or Trump but
isn't it good if they compete and we get
the best candidate
absolutely and I think there's going to
be a really big field and interestingly
enough as each additional person gets in
one might think well you know president
Trump doesn't want all these competitors
but there's a certain amount of the
Republican primary base that is voting
for him no matter what I would actually
say that Nikki Haley getting in the race
for example probably pulls more support
from a Rhonda santis than it does to
Donald Trump so the bigger the field
gets you know if Tim Scott Mike Mike
Pence Mike Pompeo the bigger it gets if
everyone gets in I think it actually
plays to president Trump's Advantage I
think having a good spirited healthy
debate and process is fantastic but
what's important is it when it's done
and there's a nominee everyone needs to
get behind that winner or Joe Biden is
going to get a second term
um
I'm about to say
about the set he's no dice
it's all good
can't believe you own a Dice Clay what
Jack
[Applause]
Jack with the joke but hey good enough
it's phenomenal so do you
do you think the bigger the field is
more practice for president Trump
because we got a ton of nicknames and a
lot of people got ruined I mean we still
looking for Mr Jeb Bush
so far his nicknames have been
um but all these articles are like I'm
hearing from my sources that Ron
DeSantis is gonna run for president what
the template is you write a book you
slim down you perpetually stand in front
of a microphone if you're a governor
you're running for president the same
template for a mature gal you get a
tummy tuck full facial waxing order a
dozen fishnets on Amazon you're
divorcing and getting ready to go
whoring
[Applause]
you're running for president being a
right
two words have never been spoken
and I say that with deep admiration
Kennedy last word to you
two things Mary Mary Quite Contrary trim
your it's so damn hairy
[Applause]
and two
I cannot wait for my fish nuts to get
here
all right I want I'm not I'm not running
for president but I'm planning on doing
a lot of in this spring
[Applause]
and you can't lose
it I see you trying different options
hope the camera doesn't cut to me
it's on you now baby
Security's not here for them it's to
make sure you don't leave
before we go
see me live I'll be in Crowley Louisiana
April 21st Houston April 23rd in
Walhalla South Carolina on May 5th visit
the link Tree on my Instagram for
tickets hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else